fox news alert this just into our  newsroom colorado governor jared polis  is now saying that the same coronavirus  variant  found in the uk which is considered more  contagious  has now been discovered in colorado  based on dr fauci's words take this very  seriously as we learn  more they are they are trying to learn  as much as they can about this  it is known to be more contagious but dr  fauci says in a new  interview it's not considered to make  you any sicker  but the colorado governor is now  identifying that this case  a case of that variant has been  discovered in colorado so we'll continue  to watch  that and bring you more on it as we get  it